it might be the a-list stars donning the
capes and masks but the real heroes of
today's CGI heavy comic-book movies are
the special-effects artists the men and
women who really make it all possible
of course if you're not convinced that's
the case just try watching those movies
before the effects were added in 2014
was a big year for Marvel movies beyond
the obvious successes of the MCU Fox
also released its eagerly awaited x-men
sequel Days of Future past as Marvel
prepared to introduce Aaron
taylor-johnson as the emcee use
Quicksilver in Avengers age of Ultron
Fox exercised its rights to use the
character by casting Evan Peters as the
lightning-fast mutant for the x-men
prequels sequel combo the film earned
rave reviews and Peter's Quicksilver was
one of its best parts with one scene in
particular making the headlines Days of
Future past now iconic super slow-mo
kitchen scene may have looked amazing on
film but it wasn't at all easy to
achieve the sequence had to be shot at a
mind-blowing 3,600 frames per second
compare that to the standard 24 for most
films a frame rate that high requires
huge amounts of light to work in an
interview with io9 Peter said it was
incredibly bright a lot of the crew and
Bryan Singer got to wear sunglasses and
the actors had to keep their eyes open
for a long long time with that bright
light just blaring at you it's like the
Sun it's brighter than the Sun it's
right there in your eyes but the end
result is so worth it you just power
through it unlike its predecessor 2016's
x-men apocalypse didn't go down too well
with the critics still it had a few
redeeming features chief among which was
yeah you guessed it quicksilver's moment
in the spotlight why mess with
perfection right although technological
advances made between Days of Future
past and apocalypse made things easier
for the effects team director Bryan
Singer still chose to approach
Quicksilver second major set-piece as
practically as possible this super
slow-mo evacuation scene may have up to
the ante from the kitchen scene in Days
of Future past but singer told then of
geek that you'd be surprised just how
much of it was real he explained
we did use certain visual effects
certain digital effects and explosive
algorithms but we also took multiple
phantom 3d cameras and ran them in
protective cases through physical
explosions just because the CGI team had
it easy however doesn't mean everyone
did we blew up our sets we waited until
we were done with them and then blew
them up we flew the cameras through at
80 miles per hour rolling at 3,000
frames per second all in all it took six
weeks to make what amounted to two
minutes of film considering how well
that scene went down with fans however
there's a good chance the crew decided
it was more than worth the effort v MCU
entry marked Chris Evans debut as Steve
Rogers a scrawny New Yorker who becomes
an all-american super soldier after
agreeing to take part in a military
experiment Evans got jacked for the role
though his bulky frame meant that
filming the scenes that take place
before he transforms into Captain
America was very tricky the visual
effects department shrunk Evans actual
body for some shots but they also used a
body double actor leander diamond the
goal was to make the audience fall in
love with the character before he gets
any muscles before he puts on a costume
before he holds his shield visual
effects put Evans face on Leigh Anders
body and although his double was
diligent about mimicking Evans body
language as best he could the effects
company still had their work cut out
comparing it to quote taking the head of
a rhinoceros and putting it on the body
of a gazelle Logan was a milestone movie
in Fox's long-running x-men franchise
not only because it was Hugh Jackman's
final bow as Wolverine but also because
it was the first time fans got to see
the clawed and mutant in all his r-rated
glory the levels of violence on display
during Logan were like nothing before
seen in the x-men universe and this
meant the VFX team had their work cut
out for them but Rising Sun Pictures VFX
supervisor Dennis Jones relished the
challenge he told art of VFX Logan is
more brutal visceral and has direct
consequences for the characters involved
the r-rating that was confirmed from the
start introduced another dynamic to play
with albeit in a restrained fashion
in the Wolverine some of our shots had
to be amended to remove blood and claw
penetration so it was great to be able
to set the character free from these
constraints but that Gore went far
beyond just computer graphics makeup
designer Joe Harlow also told the verge
that the level of physical trauma in
this film is something I haven't had to
contend with since the early years when
I was smearing blood around guardians of
the galaxy volume 2's visual effects
supervisor Chris Townsend wasn't part of
the team that worked on the first
guardians movie but he had previously
worked with Marvel on Captain America
the First Avenger and Iron Man 3
receiving an Oscar nomination for the
latter when offered the opportunity to
oversee the guardians sequel Townsend
jumped at the chance to return to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
he told the rotoscope errs I'm a huge
fan of the film's I think from a
creative and visual effects point of
view they're some of the funnest stuff
out there for the film's epic third act
in which the guardians faced ego inside
his own planet Townsend accepted a bid
from whet a digital who picked up the
action right after ego reveals to quill
that he gave his mother cancer Weta's
guy Williams told art of VFX from that
point on it is mostly our work we go all
the way until yondu and quill rise above
the planet as it is destroyed behind
them the new zealand-based visual
effects house had up to 490 staffers
working on guardians of the galaxy vol 2
at one stage according to Williams who
admitted to losing plenty of sleep over
the highly complicated nature of the
project let's face it if you're the king
of Wakanda
you've got to ride in style and with the
world's largest supply of the miracle
metal vibranium at your disposal a
rolls-royce or an Air Force One style
Boeing 747 simply won't do luckily those
wakandan engineers and scientists
clearly knew what they were doing when
they designed Black Panthers jet when
King T'Challa arrived in Wakanda from
his journeys abroad he did so on a
badass super sleek stealth plane that
looks like it came right out of area 51
you wouldn't know that if you were just
watching the raw dailies though in the
original footage there was no jet no
landing platform heck there wasn't even
any wood
we're just a handful of actors on a set
and a large blue screen in the
background it's a little jarring to see
that the mad Titan the destroyer of
civilizations the wicked warlord Thanos
is actually well it's Josh Brolin
wearing what looks like an overpriced
skin-tight bikers outfit while Brolin is
probably thankful he didn't have to wear
any space armor and paint his skin
purple for the role he was still very
much present during the filming of
infinity war and endgame thanks to the
wonders of motion capture technology
Brolin had never done mocap before but
he saw the light after seeing what his
future Avengers cast mate Benedict
Cumberbatch was able to do as smell in
the hobbit the desolation of smaug none
shall stop me
indeed Roland's one-on-one interactions
with his cast mates added an extra layer
of creepy credibility that made the mad
Titan that much scarier in the final
movies one of the most underrated
aspects of Avengers infinity war was
Peter Dinklage's performance as III the
king of the dwarves here the actor who
only stands about four foot four was
playing a twenty foot giant the Lord of
the Rings films famously used forced
perspective to make people look like
Hobbit size but this film used a
different approach instead having
Dinklage play opposite mini cutouts of
Thor Groot and Rocket Raccoon
this makes Dinklage's scene-stealing
performance that much more impressive as
he was basically performing with dolls
Chris Hemsworth who also had to act
opposite nothing would shoot his scenes
on a set while Dinklage performed
against a blue screen it's not always
easy this acting malarkey infinity wars
climactic battle of Wakanda was filmed
on an 8 thousand acre farm called
Chattahoochee Hills eventing about 40
minutes outside Atlanta instead of
thousands of extras only 70 performers
were used but they became more than 500
wakandans digitally and proceeded to do
the battle with fan OSes army of 10,000
alien monsters known as outriders which
were also digitally produced the art
department even added indigenous african
trees and created an artificial river
for the scene
with a massive pump that was gushing out
up to 30,000 gallons per minute that's a
lot of effort for something that's
barely even visible in the finished
movie
Thor's arrival at the Battle of what
condom may very well be the most epic
superhero entrance ever but when you see
what it looked like before the CGI was
added okay it's still pretty epic but
it's not quite the same as the finished
product for this scene Chris Hemsworth
donned his full Thor attire and wielded
a massive axe that just needed a little
CG love to become the mighty storm
breaker of course what he didn't have
was a smack-talking gun-toting raccoon
on his shoulder an angsty teenage tree
hundreds of wakandan warriors or an
invading army of 10,000 alien monsters
so yeah most of the stuff in the scene
was added after the fact all the more
reason to be impressed with Chris
Hemsworth's performance considering he
was basically acting by himself in a
$10,000 Halloween costume following
Hulk's vicious beat down at the hands of
Thanos and Avengers infinity war Marvel
fans were on the edges of their seats
waiting to find out what the future held
for everyone's favorite angry Green
Giant none but the most die-hard
comic-book fans would have guessed it
would be Professor Hulk
according to animation boss it was
Framestore who breathed life into end
games Bruce Banner Hulk hybrid the
process started by taking source footage
of Mark Ruffalo and matching it to
animation this animation was then used
for 60 shots with head cam footage used
for reference
according to animation supervisor max
Solomon it was absolutely about
channeling Bruce Banner his face is very
expressive every nuance every little
twitch and eidart slight curl of the lip
and muscle tension needed to be
translated VFX supervisor Stuart Penn
explained there was a lot of work
involved as their face shapes are so
different
Hulk is massive his mouth proportionally
bigger his eyes are sunken with deeper
sockets tiny changes to his face had a
huge effect on the performance having
wiped out half of all life in Infinity
Wharf a past version of Thanos returns
to earth and in game's final act in a
desperate attempt to regain the six and
the stones from the Avengers
unfortunately for him this is the first
time this version of the mad Titan has
gone up against Captain Marvel fans had
been eagerly anticipating Captain
Marvel's bout against Thanos ever since
she was teased in a post-credits scene
two Avengers infinity war after seeing
what she was capable of during both her
own movie and her handful of earlier
scenes in endgame it became clear that
the mad Titan had more than met his
match in Danvers but bringing this fight
to life on set appears to have been
considerably less epic than how it wound
up being on the big screen but hey
that's the magic of the movies for you
Tony Stark's last stand against Thanos
has to be one of the MCU s greatest ever
scenes that final line was a callback to
one first uttered eleven years prior to
endgame in Ironman
the film that launched the biggest
franchise in history and there couldn't
have been a better line for Tony Stark
to go out on
strangely enough however it almost
didn't happen during a QA that took
place in the wake of the film's release
the Russo brothers explained Tony used
to not say anything in that moment and
we were in the editing room going he has
to say something this is a character who
has lived and died by quips and our
editor Jeff Ford who's been with us all
four movies and is an amazing
storyteller said why don't we just go
full circle with it and say I am Iron
Man
and we're like get the cameras we have
to shoot this tomorrow the scene turned
out to be the last one filmed during
endgames reshoots and the behind the
scenes reality of this iconic moment was
thankfully captured by Downey's
assistant Jimmy wrench check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you